we also learned that if you're not
full-time in your gym and you have a job
outside and you're trying to do a gym as
a side hustle or something you don't do
as well as people who are
fully committed to their gym
[Music]
what is going on everyone hope you're
having a wacky wednesday um
i am fired up today i'm gonna probably
make a bunch of content because i've had
like 10 straight days of events and i
have all these questions that people
were asking me on my mind and little
anecdotes that i shared that people
found value in so
hopefully you don't mind me just sharing
those things with you now so
um the first uh two days were actually
events that we attended and spoke at uh
which is at sas academy dan martell's
event
and i was fortunate enough to be at the
speakers table which was
value in and of itself and one of the
people who was at the speakers table
with me
uh was a man named marcus rivera he was
vista's former head of
pricing packaging and products so pretty
much when they would acquire a company
um he would be the guy that would go in
and retool the entire kind of
fulfillment
structure who they were serving how they
would break down you know
the the levels of membership etc and so
for those who don't know
what vista is vista is uh i think the
world's largest
private equity firm for software um if
you put their whole portfolio together
it's over 50
they do over 50 billion a year they'll
be ranked third
i think um in the world behind like
facebook and amazon so like
uh for like software companies so
they're uh they're really really big
really really smart
and uh i was fortunate enough to sit
next to this guy for uh two days which
was awesome for me
um and one thing became really clear
when we were having dinner
um and so they have something called
vsops which is vista's um
uh sop so they're they're kind of their
standard operating procedures
and these things are so closely guarded
you need like retinol scans and like
there's like you only get access to
certain numbers of them if you're at
certain levels and then they
you your access gets removed it's like
super top secret stuff and this is
literally how they create value
how they purchase companies put their
system on top
and then increase the value of that
company and so for them their whole
mantra is
tripling their money in three years so
it's three and three and so
um one of the things that he shared with
me now obviously he couldn't share like
the
the intricacies but the concept was
really really powerful for me
and i'll tell you how we applied it at
gym launch and so
um one of the things that uh most
companies don't do
is they don't score their leads right
they don't score their prospects they
don't score their customers
based on uh the value of that customer
right
and so scoring them can be based on a
number of of
characteristics behaviors etc that that
person shows
uh to you know put them in a certain
bucket right
and uh what vista does and what they
count on is the fact that when they go
into a company when they're assessing a
company in the diligence process
that they're going to learn more about
that company that the founder and the
people in that company even know about
it
and so what they do is they parse out
the data and they start trying to find
the veins or the buckets of the most
valuable customers
once they find those buckets that vein
of customers that's more valuable
what they then do is they basically
expand and focus on that vein of high
ltv customers like
it sounds simple and one of the things
that marcos actually hit on a lot was
like he's like we
we stick to simple simple systems simple
processes and so
when when we when i've like said things
like the people who are the most
advanced never don't do the fundamentals
i feel like i've seen this at like so
many levels and
seeing this from probably you know the
biggest and probably biggest you know
software turnaround increasing value
company out there
um is pretty cool and so let me tell you
what we did
to kind of go through this process and
so marcos was explaining that
they don't even just do it for customers
they do it for prospects
opportunities and uh and customers so
three different segments
they're going to look and score at each
each part of the pipeline
all right using the analytics that they
have in the teams that they do now
you're like okay cool that's
awesome alex how does this make more
money at my gym
and so let me tell you how we're
applying it right now and so what we did
um is we took the last 90 days i think
it was
july uh july august september or maybe
it was september
i think yeah i think it was july august
september so it took a 90-day
um block of time and we looked at all of
our exits
all of our escalations uh what the with
the people who kind of kind of suck the
most
are people who didn't get the most
results whatever you want to put it uh
the people were the
the hardest to serve uh and who got the
least results using our program
and then we looked at the the
conversation the reverse of that what
were the characteristics of the people
who made the most
money who got the highest returns who
were the easiest to work with right
and so we found here's some unsurprising
facts
um if you are not a gym owner right uh
you don't do as well as people who are
gym owners
crazy crazy facts right um and we also
learned that if you're not full-time in
your gym and you have a job outside and
you're trying to do a gym as a side
hustle or something you don't do as well
as people who are
fully committed to their gym if you
don't have a signed lease
or an or a building of your own you
don't do as well as someone who has a
building of their own
right and if you uh don't have any
employees it's harder for you
uh to do this mostly because there's a
huge time constraint right like it takes
effort to implement new systems because
not only do you have to keep your
existing business going you have to
start working on top of that
in order to dig yourself out of the hole
right and so when we found those
characteristics what we started doing
is we started uh filtering and
qualifying our front end and so we
started doing this uh for the month of
october all right so we
we took the 90 days we found we took the
findings and then we implemented for the
month of october right now we're in
november
and what's crazy is this from
the the previous four weeks so in
september the last four weeks
compared to after we started doing this
qualification
there's two crazy two crazy numbers i'm
going to share with you
one is once we qualify prospects that
they had to have at least 25 clients
they had to have assigned lease they had
to be a full-time gym owner right and
ideally this was optional but ideally
have one employee or more who worked
with them so that they could
share the load and so that they could
actually focus more on selling and you
know working leads etc
when we looked at the after effect of
that
our sales decreased from uh over 100 a
month
uh in terms of gyms to about 40 to 50.
right
now here's where it gets interesting all
right so that cut our inflow in half by
qualifying our customers right by by
really making sure that the people were
coming in were the best fit
who could serve the best right here's
what's cool on our side now that we've
done this in the first four weeks
in the four week period since then the
people who
started after those qualifications we've
had
zero escalations from those people
prior to that we have we had 22
escalations as in people who
were having issues uh you know whatever
it is you know i mean just red flags
right
um the the prior four weeks so from 22
to zero now think how crazy this is in
terms of scaling a business and
operational
uh complexity as you go up right so we
we had this huge vein of people who were
taking up the vast majority of my team's
time
and were actually worth less right they
made less they were worthless to
us and so when you're thinking about
scaling and maintaining
operational efficiency and profit if
you're looking at the customers that
that are the highest lifetime value the
best customers right and here's what's
crazy
the people so after that october date um
we switched back to the defined end
program which is what we did for
you know three years so we did a a brief
stint where we uh where we basically
signed people up for a year
up front because we wanted to give them
everything it was it was a trial we did
a 90-day sprint
and uh it turned out that that didn't
work nearly as well as having defined it
and it's kind of the same way you run
the gyms it's like having a defined end
program
tends to be a little bit more it's a
little bit easier for people to wrap
their heads around a little more defined
in terms of the skills that they need to
acquire
etc but what's interesting is that the
people who uh came back in were actually
paying
more than the the people who
uh were paying more than the people who
who we were letting
before so this this new vein of customer
who's higher qualified
is paying more is making more requires
less work
now that sounds like a recipe for a
higher profit business right
it also sounds like a recipe for better
happier customers
and so also what happens if you think
about it from a reputation standpoint
it's like
if you lower the bar too much then what
happens is you bring in people who are
not qualified
right they take up more of your team's
time they cost you
tons of effort and they're not making as
much which means that then
they say like your thing is not as good
right when in reality it might just not
be as good
for them right which makes sense i mean
like it makes intuitive sense and so
i just like sharing these these mistakes
learns with you so that
maybe i can look back on this 10 years
from now and be like hey i remember when
we started doing that
um but now what our focus is is cool
we know who the best customers for us
are and it's like dear god why did this
take us three years to do this
you know like you know learn from my
stupidity like hopefully you can start
doing this with your own stuff
um and now we're just gonna focus and
double down on
that vein of customers and try and
expand that by really focusing on
on them in multiple platforms right and
so um
i say this to say if vista has has
repeatedly you know been able to go from
i mean
they're not a super old firm you know
from basically nothing all the way to 50
billion in a very short period of time
it's because
they know how to extract and amplify
value and the biggest thing is not
change i mean they do shirt they tweak
the pricing they find the right buckets
etc
but they do that by analyzing the
customers better than the business that
they're purchasing
purchasing even knows their own
customers and so i challenge you
now this may sound like super analytical
it's not all you have to do is look over
the last three months
okay look at the people who left your
business all right this is where you get
the the best data is from all the people
who leave
right so look at the data from people
who left your business
try and get as like to think about as
many character traits as you possibly
can
what's their age what's their you know
what's their job
uh what are their goals what do they
sign up for how much money down did they
start with
um what did they sign up for in terms of
their continuity etc
and if you can if you can piece those
things together then you're going to get
a really good idea
of of uh of who the good customers are
who the bad customers are
and it's okay to have a stern line
because we're doing this now
now the thing is is like in the in the
short term you can be like oh my gosh my
inflow cut in half
but so did all my operational overhead
and and the issues that
like all that work that the team had to
put together um
to try and service these people who were
not necessarily the best fit
right and so um i share that with you
and i'll give you one more tidbit that
i learned from him and so uh we learned
this from the from the whole event which
we took is a huge takeaway for us that
you can totally apply to your gym
is that customers in a recurring base
business or really any business
decide whether they're going to stay at
two points in the beginning of your life
cycle
all right between the sale and when they
start getting the thing
right the service the product the
whatever and
once they start using the product the
implementation or onboarding period
so in that period so if you're doing an
orientation with your clients right
they buy something all right the time
between the purchase
and when they start getting the thing
which would be your orientation and
the actual orientation itself is
typically when people are already making
the decision of when they
want whether they're going to stay with
you in the long run
all right which means if right now
you just think your your orientation is
an aftermath it's like oh yeah now we
have to fulfill that thing we sold
you're screwed right you're getting by
just on the fact that like you're you
have enough volume in the door
but you're losing massive amounts of
money by not making that a
completely choreographed experience that
you're really focusing on
over delivering a value and the way to
do that
is to demonstrate the skills that
they're going to need to be able to
use to use your services right and so
whether that like
not just not just saying hey yeah you
should download this app yeah
you'll figure it out but actually doing
it with them holding their hand
and then having them duplicate the
process so that you can see that you've
transferred the skill to them
so that they now know and they are
self-sufficient in being
able to consume your services right and
so
if your onboarding is rushed right your
orientation is rushed
then expand the time period because it's
going to massively multiply the lifetime
value of that customer and the
likelihood
that they're going to stay with you so
this is one of those few times where you
don't want to be lazy
um and not and not deliberate and
intentional
in how you're onboarding the customer
after you complete the sale
so the communication that you have with
them immediately after the sale which is
like
sending them a personalized video you
know giving them swag maybe a letter
whatever it is
definitely texting them between the time
that they make the sale or you make the
sale
and when they start the onboarding and
the second piece i'm already going back
to the big
beginning is the sale itself and so what
we're learning
internally for us at gym watch and this
may seem obvious but maybe i'm sharing
it with you because we're learning it
too
is that expectations are everything
right
expectations are everything and if you
set proper expectations for what is
going to happen next and then you
fulfill that beautifully
your trust with the prospect goes up now
here's where it can get
uh tricky right and this is what we call
selling hot it's where you
where you set expectations so high it's
impossible for you to ever fulfill
or for you to hit that with the majority
of customers
right and so this is where
selling towards behavior and selling
towards sustainability and long-term
change
comes really into play so that you can
shift and break the beliefs of your
prospect
to shifting their time frame to what is
really going to be beneficial for them
rather than um simply trying to sell
them to say
yes right and so um an example of this
is you know for us if if someone has
only consumed testimonial and we've
we've changed this in our marketing
we've changed this in our testimonials
we've changed it in the in the post that
we tag people in
is that we're really no longer focused
on on saying like hey look at these
10 people who made a hundred grand in
their first you know
six weeks with us right we have those
right we totally do
but the thing is is like but what are
the averages right and so now we just
share what the average
gym does all right and it's
significantly less you know appealing i
think the average gym right now is like
they do 16 000 in their first six weeks
with us
right now that's a lot but it's not a
hundred grand in your first month
and and showing what the average gyms
are getting in terms of leak costs and
lead flow
gives people at least an average
understanding and we can explain to the
person that means that half the people
who sign up get
less than this right this is the average
and so
that way um if you if and when you do go
above that mark
then their expectations are reasonable
and you can over deliver
right um and in an ideal world you would
probably try and
sell on the bottom 25 of results
so that the expectations are so low that
everyone is
excited about the fact that they're over
achieving from that
um from that baseline that you have set
for them and so what i've like i'm
continuing to learn this i like want to
write like a whole presentation on
expectations
but expectation management is everything
right it's amazing what happens if you
set uh really high expectations
and like this is where this is where
someone makes 20
000 in their first month and is
disappointed
with gym launch and we've had this
happen plenty of times right
they're like well this sucks i thought i
was gonna do better right
when in reality that's [ __ ] amazing
right
um in terms of the big scheme now maybe
this resonates with you because you've
had someone who loses
five pounds in their first 14 days with
you and they're disappointed
now why would they be disappointed only
one reason
because the expectations that were set
for them in the sale and
in the orientation were were too high
for the average person and then most
people are disappointed with what would
otherwise be considered
an amazing great start and so if you can
reset
the expectations that are being uh put
on the customer
in the sale right and you sell around
the fact
uh not around yourself through the fact
and you break the belief around what the
expectation should be
in a short and long-term vision so that
you can shift their expectations towards
long-term change
and a process and behavior change so
that they can ultimately achieve what
they want
which is being fit forever not fit for
the next six weeks or six months
right and so um all that to say
the big takeaways that we have at gym
launch is that we are now
heavily qualifying people on the front
end so that we have
longer lifetime value we have superior
client outcomes we have
less operational complexity because
these people have the right
characteristics of people who are
successful
both externally in terms of like what
they have their gym but
internally in terms of how they work um
and how like what level of effort
they're willing to put in to be
successful
right we found out that entrepreneurs
are not a very good uh
demographic for us and so it's like cool
we're not gonna service them right we're
not going to service them
in this way maybe we'll create an info
product that's
um less for them so that they can go
through it at their own leisure
their own time frame rather than the
intense time frame that we
put onto people uh when they start gym
launch because it's really like ready
fire
go you know you have 72 hours and leads
are starting to come in right and that's
how we do things in gym lunch because
that's how i am
right um but we have now used this on
the qualification side and then also how
our sales people are tagging and setting
expectations
and then being extremely deliberate and
we're still working on this um
in making the onboarding and
implementation even more choreographed
and we have a pretty darn choreographed
uh orientation process but even better
even
even
more reinforced even simpler uh so that
the handoff is seamless
so that everyone knows exactly what is
going to happen before it happens
and then they know exactly what is going
to happen next uh in their experience
with us and so you can use this
all these these lessons that we're
learning right now um in your business
so that you can
increase the quality of the customer set
the expectations properly
and then over deliver on the
expectations that you've set so that
they can make
the decision in the first two or three
meetings with you that they're gonna
stick with you for the long haul
so i hope this was valuable for you like
it uh drop a drop a comment
drop a review if you're listening this
on the podcast um and uh
as usual if you uh want some free
goodies you can
you know download them somewhere you can
go to alex'sbook.com if you want more
stuff like this
uh and get a free book anyways lots of
love keep being awesome and have an
amazing wacky wednesday and i'll catch
you guys on the flip side all right
[Music]
you